so this morning we're having an
executive session on
house bill 1037 and other bills that
we're ready to vote on
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
i would move
amendment 0071
h
to house bill 1037.
okay
is there a second
thing thanks representative
do you wish to speak to your motion
yes thank you um
at the time that we had the hearing and
discussed this bill
i heard from members of the committee
that
they felt the line for informational
purposes only
was
not necessary
and that
members of the committee preferred to
leave the language in order to ensure
transparency
so that's all that this amendment does
and i had promised that i would produce
it and here it is
thank you for doing as you said
representative marsh do you wish should
speak to your second i'm content with
what's been said thank you
okay
thank you representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman
the the amendment in the bill
does absolutely nothing to change
anything that that is going to happen
with this information
and you know taking out the
the verbiage for informational purposes
only does not change the reason why
you're actually still giving the
information
and
i will not be supporting the amendment
because it it does absolutely
nothing
thank you other other comments
in that case the motion is to pass
amendment number
zero zero seven one
zero zero seven one h
all right
the clerk can call the roll
representative
mike
no
thank you
representative rhodes votes no
clerk let's know
representative pearson
i'm gonna vote no
representative jacobovich
not here yet i'm sorry thank you
representative
yes
representative allegro no
representative bailey
yes
representative lanzara yes
represent santa anastasia yes
representative goalie
yes
representative short
yes representative judy oui
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh
yes representative fellows
yes
yes yes i have that representative grota
yes representative o'brien um this is
here resident horrigan substituting for
russian o'brien's i vote yes
and the chair and
yes
i wish i'd been here for the caucus
um
there are four no's
there are abundant yeses
we do the vote is 13 to 4 so the
amendment passes we do have two absences
representative
fontenot and jacobovic
so representative schuett you have a
motion
sure
i will move out to pass with amendment
is there a second
representative
did you just speak to your
motion well i think it's pretty much uh
what i said about the amendment okay
thank you representative marsh you're
nodding in agreement okay
is there any discussion
representative pearson i you know again
at the end of the day
this does not change the governor's day
in any way in any form it doesn't change
what the governor's office whoever that
governor maybe does it doesn't change
the way they do anything with
information whatsoever
so it really to me serves no purpose
at all
okay anyone else
represent judy do you wish to speak are
you
okay thank you
representative representative made the
motion it was seconded by representative
marsh again okay
and
okay
anyone else
seeing none
all right the motion is ought to pass
with amendment the clerk can call the
roll
representative rhodes
no
clerk votes yes
representative pearson no
representative uh lekkas yes
representative allegro
no
representative bailey
representative lonzara no
representative santo nostasso
yes
representative goalie
representative short
yes representative judy we
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative
uh grota
uh representative harrigan yes
uh
five
twelve i guess uh
damn it
11 6 thank you that's the same should be
the same number as the previous
the vote motion is 11 to 6.
put
i don't think we should put it on
consent although i'd love to i'd love to
and i must say i'm rather
disappointed well never i'm rather
disappointed that we bothered to pass
this bill after
amending it but
all right
on house bill 60 1062
there is an amendment
which is
uh
i believe it's been passed around
you have it okay
that amendment
removes
one section of the bill
which was
thought to be inappropriate
and i had to agree so i've come up with
an amendment to delete
the
the oh
i'm i'm moving ought to pass that
amendment
is there a second
thank you representative marsh
okay
and the
at the hearing this this bill simply
deletes some of the the advisory
committee
responsibilities so that they're
done by the oplc
part two
would delet would delete
the rule-making authority over the
content and conduct of
the examinations
and i tend to after it was pointed out
to me i tend to agree that's exactly
what we want rules for
the content of the exam and what the
practical exam is
so
the amendment simply deletes part two
agreed
okay representative marsh do you wish to
speak to your second
i'm good thank you okay
does anyone else wish to speak
representative i just have a question
by removing that section
and i'm not looking at the original
language does that leave the rule making
as it currently is in law yes thank you
yes the as amended this only changes the
specific responsibility of the advisory
board over the examinations
okay
that's amendment number
o211h
yes represent fellows
so in the part that we're keeping which
is in section a one of the things that's
deleted is
the
committee
has been
responsible for determining applicant
performance on the competency exam
can you shed any light on
how that was done and and how
um
the director of oplc will do it now
i'm
believe that the difference is that they
are
evaluating the scores
this will allow oplc to contract with an
outside professional organization to
conduct the exams
so
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and
thank you for bringing forward this
amendment it was
myself that brought
this uh change to your attention and i'm
glad to see that you had this amended
out because i had concerns with removing
content and conduct
in there and so i thank you for that and
i'll be supporting this
anyone else
comment
okay the motion is to adopt amendment
0211h to house bill 1062
made by me seconded by representative
marsh the clerk can call the role
representative rhodes
yes
clerk yes representative pearson yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lanzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes
representative judy oui
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota yes representative
horrigan yes
and the chair
18-0
okay then i move that we adopt house
bill 1062 as amended
is there a second
second
and i'm not going to say anything more
representative schmidt
same thing
is there any discussion representative
goalie
just real briefly madam chair
during the testimony making this
advisory
i asked the specific question as to
whether the executive director would be
in consultation with the boards when
they
hire out for these exams and it was
stated that they would and if that could
be in
the committee report that would be great
just so we have some record that that
discussion took place here during the
committee i would appreciate it
thank you that's a good point this is
is and has been an advisory board for a
while but definitely the they should be
well consulted before
anything on the exam
may i just make one comment
representation
i did appreciate the statement that you
made
during the hearing on the bill
and would hope that you could
incorporate some of that
into the statement on passage because
that definitely establishes legislative
intent
that oplc should just be administrative
and the technical part should go to the
board
thank you
any other comments questions
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so
this is clearly an issue that we have
discussed on several other bills
uh and being on the record is not just
uh you know
when we say for the record i'm so-and-so
and so-and-so that's a formality but uh
the reality is we have to establish this
idea that the executive that the oplc is
going to be
the
chief administrative end of things and
that the
stakeholders and are the experts on the
substance of their profession uh and we
want the oplc to to be on the record and
to establish that firmly so this is a
good idea thank you
any other comments
okay seeing none that case the motion is
ought to pass as amended on house bill
the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
clerk yes representative pearson yes
representative jacob
yes representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lanzara yes
representative santos
yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett
yes representative judy louis
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative
yes representative of
horrigan or uh yes
and the chair yes
looks like it's the same 18-0
okay that's 18-0 does anyone object to
consent
okay we will put that one on consent
representative yakubovic you have a
motion on house bill
yes
yes madam chair i would like to pass
the amendment
last week
it is
the amendment zero one nine two h to
fifteen eighty one
is there a second
second representative like a second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes please um this is something we did
in this subcommittee the five of us uh
voted well unanimously to to move
forward with this amendment we consult
consulted with the sponsor and the
director of it
and this we believe is the proper role
for the bill right here in the amendment
we are modifying only one section one
sentence and this is what the amendment
shows
hey thank you representative blackish do
you wish to speak to it
uh that's fine no okay any other
comments
discussion
madam chair could you just repeat the
amendment number
zero one nine two h okay that is the
surroundings
do we have an extra copy don't seem to
have one
i'm sorry
any other comments discussion questions
i'd like to thank the subcommittee for
coming up with such an elegant solution
to the
to these two bills
nice job
thank you okay the motion is to adopt
amendment
0192h to house bill 1581 and the clerk
can call the rule representative rhodes
yes
clerk yes representative pearson yes
representative jacobovic yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lunzara yes
representative santa mustafa yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative judy we
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh
yes representative fellows yes
representative grota yes
representative horrigan yes
and the chair
sounds like 18 to 0.
um yes uh otpa on 1581
well second as well again
um
is there any more discussion
apparently not
okay
in that case the motion is ought to pass
with amendment on house bill 1581 and
the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
clark cs representative pearson yes
representative jacobovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes represent
representative lanzaro yes
representative sanchez
yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes representative judy oui
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative grote yes
representative horrigan yes
and the chair yes 18 0.
does anyone object to consent
okay seeing none we'll put that one on
consent
all right
representative pearson you have a motion
on house bill 1123
i do and i want to begin
by
mentioning
uh that this was
initially thought that we would
handle this in a subcommittee but really
after looking at it and the testimony
we're going to it seems appropriate to
do this without it so my motion
is an itl on
23.
is there a second
second second
okay representative rhodes got in first
do you wish to speak to your motion i do
thank you madam chair
we
had ample testimony as to how the state
currently
handles
its purchase
its bidding process
and its overall
opinion of biofuels
and what we learned from that testimony
is that
that is a
robust and ongoing
process that the state is currently
under in reference to the the use
purchase bidding and
desire to use biofuels
so taking the testimony of the
department of transportation in
reference to what is outlined in 1123
what became glowingly obvious is that
we're already doing it
so frankly that makes 1123
unnecessary in the sense that
the dot is pretty much already doing
this
and that pretty much sums up the uh
the occurrence
of the state versus 1123.
wherever set rhodes do you wish to speak
to your second
thank you madam chair i i don't have
anything more to add that was already
said by mr representative pearson
all right is there any comments
discussion representative phillips
i would just like to say that i'm glad
we heard this bill because i learned a
lot about biofuels because i think it's
a great idea to use biofuels but we
heard why it's so difficult primarily
because if you have a
truck then you're going to fill the fuel
that's with 10 percent biofuels then you
can only deliver it to people who want
that 10 mix so
i agree with the itl but i'm glad we
heard this bill
thank you representative fellows other
comments
representative scitec i'll have what
she's having
thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so i spoke with my
local fuel distributorship about the
subject and it's pretty clear that uh
what what people have been saying up to
this point is the case that this is a
it's being done uh by the state and b
this is an ongoing situation a
developing situation but but it ain't
there yet uh statewide and uh i believe
representative uh sampson said that he
spoke with his fuel oil distributor and
the person said find me 30 more people
and i'll handle it
and i've arranged without
one of the leadership over at my
fuel and distributorship and he said i'd
be happy to speak with your delegation
about this subject because it is
something you need to know more about
but it's not ready for prime time in
this area at least not over on the
seacoast so
this bill is not necessary
anyone else
and i'd have to say that i agree that
the
we or the state is already looking into
biofuels but the bill as written doesn't
do very much to enforce that looking so
i think it's somewhat redundant to
existing statute
and they'll be already flat
exactly
all right seeing no other questions the
motion is itl by representative pearson
and house bill
1123 the clerk can call the role
representative rhodes yes clerk votes
yes representative pearson yes
representative jacob
yes representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzaro yes
representative santos
yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes representative judy louis
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh
no
representative fellows yes
representative uh grota
yes
representative hargan
no
okay 16-2
oh and the chair sorry
yes
it's still 16
no 17
18 16
still short one member so it would be 16
to 2.
uh representative marsh oh actually is
there any objection to consent
no okay we'll put this one on consent
okay
i think we can get
representative pearson you have a motion
on house bill 1590.
i do madam chair
i would like to make the motion of
giving folks a second to find it
to 1590 yep to itl 1590.
second
hey
do you wish to speak to your motion i do
thank you madam chair the
the concept brought forward
um
in this bill is
while some may argue may have some merit
in the overall concept the practical
reality
of this is
extraordinarily more complicated
and
they're
frankly the
the person that brought this forward
really had no concept of of that at all
in in terms of what the
what the complications are and was
frankly not even familiar with how the
retirement system's funded so
this would
the the problems that this would create
are are too
large
to agree to put this into any sort of
statute
i mean i'm not going to go down the road
of what
the multitude of problems are but it's
um as we as we all saw in the testimony
and the back and forth
that there are multiple substantial
elements that would have to be included
with this in order to make it even
somewhat feasible and they're just not
here so that's why my recommendation is
uh or my motion is itl
representative goalie
thank you ma'am chair i will just add
that there currently is in statute a way
for
these
cities and towns to withdraw if they so
choose
so there's no need of this thank you
thank you representative marsh
yes i went to echo representative goalie
the towns can withdraw from the
retirement system upon payment of the
current unfunded uh
balance uh actually determined so i
don't think this bill is necessary
okay
anyone else
i'd like to add that that clause has
been in statute
for decades
no municipality has ever
withdrawn from the retirement system
because the ones that thought about it
looked at the costs
and decided they couldn't afford it
so
as long as it's already in statute i
don't think this bill adds anything to
existing law
yes
yes um i will vote no on the itl because
i do believe the towns should have an
option
a better option to withdraw if they they
no longer value the system thank
you representing broda
i'm going to vote on the itl motion
because although towns do have the
um
ability to leave the system they
shouldn't leave without paying their
debt
i'm going to vote for the itl um
i understand what they're trying to do
and i have some sympathy but
the bill did not include anything about
them paying the ual and that's a problem
yes thank you and i'd like to mention
that the
the cost for one year for the retiree
for the
employees is going to be
significantly less than the amount
required to pay off the ual for those
those retirees it would be
something on the order of 18 times as
much plus interest
so
i'm not sure that
i think that the towns that are asking
for this would have the same same issue
thank you ma'am chair so one of the
things i think is the real danger with
this is that if you get an uh award
article to uh to uh to do this in a
particular town uh you might start uh
a
a brush fire that would uh run out of
control before people really understand
what they're letting themselves in for
uh and that now you've got something
that
that they really don't want to do even
if they think they want to do
representative pearson i just i just
want to also add to to remind folks you
know that the definition of employee in
the retirement system is not the
definition of employee that we all think
it is and i think that that's something
too that
needs to be reminded
that a
a fire person a police person a
corrections person a teacher none of
them are employees
they are in our minds but as far as the
retirement systems go that is not what
they are
so
i think that sometimes we get a little
bit caught up in in some of the language
and we think something's going to do
something it's not and in this case
you've just removed a massive amount of
people
out of this and
i don't know that that's really the goal
here of of what the sponsor brought
forward
thank you madam chair
um i think the sum total of most of the
comments here just
indicate that there was kind of a
misunderstanding of
the entire process
on the part of the
sponsor and the people that he was
representing
lots of unintended consequences could
result from this
and i definitely will support itl thank
you
any other comments
questions
okay the motion is an expedient to
legislate on 1590
the
clerk can call the roll
can he
representative rhodes
yes
clerkwoods yes representative pearson
yes representative yakovich
no
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
no
representative zara yes
represent representative santana
no
representative goalie yes
representative
yes
representative judy we representative
schmidt yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative grota yes
representative hargan yes
and the chair
yes
15-3
do any of you wish to write a minority
report
okay in that case this will be going on
the regular calendar
who's writing that
so what was the vote
madam chair i have a motion on a
wonderful bill
i'm over here
house bill 1030
which is representative edward's bill
about including the two
branches of government that were
i'm sorry i thought we already voted on
that did we vote on that already
10 30.
the
tactical experience for uh
lnas
no
it's representative edward's bill on
including no no i i remember well i just
thought did we did we not did we vote on
that already
no we already know it was too late in
the afternoon okay
i vote otp i might make a motion on atp
i'll second that as the author of 10 30.
would you like to make the motion
no it's all you
okay
thank you folks for catching that
because i
i left it off off my list because i
thought we'd already done it
mia culpa representative grota
well this bill adds two branches of
government that were inadvertently
omitted in the original drafting of the
first bill and it's really a sensible
and
practical
move to include these two additional
branches of government
thank you representative pearson
thank you madam chair yes the this was
passed two years ago signed by the
governor and placed into law
with um
with a broken promise by the senate that
they would fix the mistake that was made
by myself when i drafted it two years
ago
the other thing too it was brought up
and i'll just remind folks the space
force was in fact mentioned but the
space force does not have medics they
are supplied by the air force
the bill also
has a little
caveat at the end about or others
qualifying
in the or others was done to prevent us
from having to go in and
wiggle this thing around if the military
changes a code because the original
language had very specific
military code designations which as we
learned in testimony has been changed
over time
so this would this would allow us to not
have to
revisit this every time the
military decides to change a code it
it gives the
the equivalency of that so
i think this will continue to help with
our substantial shortage in
the lna world
and is kind of a no-brainer in my mind
thanks
anyone else
representative
yeah i'd just uh like to apologize for
uh instigating the whole mention of the
space force i sent an email to reps uh
pearson and edwards
and you know joking about it because of
some of the games of inner service
rivalry and i will note that my
salutation was with tongue firmly in
cheek so thank you
thank you i like the idea that it's
broad enough to cover a
code renumbering because that could
happen at any time out of our control
and i will say that probably most
military medics are overqualified to be
lna so i'd like to
at least get them working while they're
getting their nursing degrees
and if she would you had a comment
or i was going to shoe it
you don't okay anyone have a comment
yeah yeah
how do you talk tongue-in-cheek how do
you do that
briefly very briefly
anyone else have a comment about the
bill representative schmidt
thank you ma'am sure so
as those senior members will remember we
we have had a number of bills over the
years representative baldassaro has
brought in bills on a number of
occasions with regard to supporting
our military uh personnel who come in
either themselves with some expertise in
some area
uh or
very often a spouse and so i think we
already have a fair
indication of support and have taken
steps in that direction
to help our military people uh so
we're on record and we're working to do
this on this to degree this results from
an error well
well
retracted all right anyone else have a
comment
okay seeing none the motion is ought to
pass on house bill 1030 by
representative grota the clerk can call
the role representative rhodes
yes clark votes yes representative
pearson yes representative yakovich yes
representative yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative lanzaro yes
representative santo anastaso yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes representative judy we
representative schmidt yeah
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota yes
representative
yes and the chair
yes
18 to 0.
any objections to consent
okay seeing none we'll put that on
consent
does anyone else have another bill they
think is ready for exec
it's it's we need an amendment that is
not yet available
do we have the fellows amendment
is that ready
if it's not ready it's not ready
we won't
okay i run out of forms oh well in that
case we'll have to stop
madam chair
are we ready to
pick up something else
are we ready to take up something
else if you have something that is ready
for an exact i believe so um
i would move interim study on house bill
that's the midwifery bill
the subcommittee has not yet met on that
so i think i will
i'd like to wait until the subcommittee
has had a chance to go through it all
right thank you i i
had
marked it subcommittee question mark but
i haven't seen scheduling yet yes it's
in representative pearson's subcommittee
and he has a lot of
changes he needs to make to clarify i
will i will bring my idea to the
subcommittee
yes the fourth right friday
the fourth
yeah that is not an early bill despite
my earlier concept so it there's time to
go through it we can consider interim
study
in a month or so well my i will just
state that my idea of
moving interim study is to try and get
the oplc and the board
to make their own solution
ah that might be a good if you could
manage that representative shoot i will
be seriously impressed
madam chair are we ready to exact house
bill 1016.
remind us of which one is 1016.
relative to licensing of speech language
specialists i did bring an amendment
forward but i believe that the testimony
that we heard was that everybody was in
agreement with that amendment and i
would be glad to make a motion if you
wish
i believe representative like is that's
in your subcommittee
not that you're aware of oh
1016.
yeah i know
but clearly there were there's issues
with it and
i was
if you needed to see it
i've seen the amendment
the amendment addre
addresses the issue of
not create not adding new people to the
existing title which would violate the
the interstate
compact but it also removes the
control of the speech language
specialist from the department of
education which is a good idea
representative pearson i just have a
question you
having dealt with and not being a fan of
interstate compacts
this has this or has this not been
vetted through our current interstate
compact representative marsh
the the interstate compact is in effect
at this time if that's your question no
i know it's in effect but does this vi
this doesn't violate the interstate
compact uh the bill as drafted would
violate the interstate compact the bill
with my amendment would not and that's
one of the things that's behind my
amendment okay
all right anyone else have a
or represent fellows i i just have a
question
maybe you can
address this
on the amendment on line
which is department of education
rule making
it eliminates the ability to to
set fees and
conduct the background it takes the
responsibility for speech language
specialists entirely out of the
department of education
and lets the
board of speech language pathologists
and hearing
hearing
whatever business people
license the speech language specialists
and then the schools are required to
hire them
my understanding of the amendment is it
it takes licensing of speech language
pathologists out of education
speech language pathologists were never
licensed they had to get more than one
license so
but in the allied health
there's
there isn't any there isn't any
licensing of speech language specialists
the amendment i believe adds that
i think we're i think we need to
i think this needs a quite a bit of
discussion
do you do you think we can finish it
before in the next half hour or so
okay representative lucas
yeah i think um the issue is uh
speech language specialist that
term or profession is basically obsolete
and
and all of the speech-language people
that are hired by the schools are
speech-language pathologists however the
statute requires that they hire speech
language specialist so what happens is
people get licensed as a speech language
pathologist with the appropriate board
and then they have to go to the
department of education and get language
i mean licensed as a speech language
specialist which is basically redundant
and meaningless in order to get employed
and this gets rid of that and represent
marsh can you correct me if i've got
that wrong
uh you have that essentially correct
there remain 20 uh older speech language
specialists under the employee and they
would be allowed to continue to work as
long as they are working in the jobs
that they are currently correct yeah
they're grandfathered
and i will mention that there is in
other statutes requirements for the
schools to conduct background checks on
all employees
so it doesn't need to be
given in this bill
so i'm
i'm just looking at it from the
technical point of view of that
paragraph that includes
line
28 29 and 30. if you cross it out of
there then they can't set fees
so they can't set the renewal they can't
set the fee because they are no longer
doing the licensing
right now there's a a certification for
the speech language specialists that
they are required to pay a fee to the
department of
of education
my understanding is that they still have
20 of them
in their database
that are qualified because they were
licensed in the past and they keep
renewing that license
senator black is overactive represented
march first i think yes that that is
addressed by lines 13 uh through 19 of
the amendment uh where that uh duty is
passed to oplc
and would no longer rest with the
department of education
you don't think so
no i
maybe it's because i'm talking about
such a minut thing here
but if we take it out of that particular
paragraph
then they can't
they can't have peace they can't
thank you representative
i hope so um
as representative march uh mentioned you
start at line 13
it says notwithstanding paragraph a any
person practicing speech language
pathology as a speech language
specialist certified by the department
of education prior to
july 1 2022 shall be eligible to
continue practicing as a speech language
specialist so long as such person
practices
continuously after july 1 2022
in a public school system or some other
schools
and such person shall not be eligible to
participate in the audiology and speech
language so what it basically says is if
they were a speech language pathologist
as of july 1 2022 they can keep
practicing they don't need to renew
they're all set that's correct
as a specialist as a specialist
and yes it does delete the fee authority
for the department of education but i
think they can get by without it
i'll go along with that
representative pearson thank you you
know i
any anytime we phase something out
it's you know important to recognize
those that that are grandfathered in the
in their current
role and i think that this absolutely
accomplishes that and protects that the
other thing too is you know this is
another bizarre situation in statute
where we had two different entities
requiring fees and licenses
that that we would have really should
have never done so you know the one-stop
shopping concept here i think is
is the way to go and
based on what um mr appleby from the
department of education said he didn't
seem to be concerned with this
at least the fee part of it in any way
so
so i think that that
you know we just we're just going to
transition this into
into disappearing when these 20 folks
are finished
i i'm okay it's such a minor point it's
not even worth redoing an amendment for
so thank you thank you representative
fellows
and as long as the as the department
doesn't need the money and it seems like
they don't i'm not
i'm okay with not charging a fee to
those few people
all right any other comments questions
who seconded representative marsha's
amendment good who seconded the motion
on the amendment i don't believe we made
a motion i asked you if we could do the
spill okay i'll be glad to make a motion
if you would like me to do so
representative
in that case i move on house bill 1016
that we adopt amendment zero zero nine
one h
and ref okay the motion made by
representative marsh seconded by
representative leckus
have we is there anyone else who wishes
to discuss the amendment uh i will just
say that this does three things it
preserves the jobs of the speech
language specialists it preserves the
title of the speech-language pathologist
and allows continued participation in
the interstate compact
and
we will continue to allow the people to
work in the schools as they are right
now so i think it accomplishes all the
goals that we wanted to accomplish thank
you
thank you representative lucas that
covered it
representative judy yes thank you
um
when i see the fee for an initial
registration under this section
shall not exceed
300 dollars
i feel that uh that 300
is uh
too expensive
give us the line reference
on the amendment not the bill itself oh
okay the whole bill would be placed by
the amendment oh i said thank you i'm
sorry
copies of it floating around
during the after the hearing but uh i
can't find mine so
are they on the table
i had some in my folder i just passed
out all but my last one so thank you
i've got one i got one i have one
somewhere
okay i've done a little staple
thank you thank you
yeah i've got one too but i left the
bill behind
me
there's yes it we can get copies of this
no problem
okay
and
and there are no fees in the in the bill
as amended
so
okay any further discussion on amendment
zero zero nine one h
okay seeing none the motion is it to
adopt the amendment made by
representative marsh the clerk can call
the role
representative
yes
missed the clerk your microphone yes
representative goalie
did you say yes
representative schuett votes yes i
didn't hear my name
representative show it
yes
representative judy oui
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes
representative grota
yes representative harrigan yes and the
chair
yes
18 same 18-0
okay person march do you have a motion
uh yes thank you madam chair i move
house bill 1016 ought to pass as amended
it's with amendment in this committee it
it hasn't been amended yet i'm sorry i
thought we just passed the amendment but
we did
ought to pass with amendment i'm going
to learn your language
i appreciate that is there a second
representative like at seconds
is there
representative marsh do you need to
speak anymore
i think i think i've said all i need to
say represent black us
okay is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on the bill
all right in that seeing none the motion
is ought to pass with amendment on house
bill 1016
made by representative marsh and the
clerk can call the role representative
rhodes
yes clark books yes representative
pearson yes representative
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzaro yes representative santo nestaso
yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative judy oui representative
schmidt aye
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative grota yes
representative hargan yes and the chair
yes
18-0
okay the motion passes 18-0 does anyone
object to consent
seeing none we'll put that one to
consent
all right i think that's about all we
can handle for for today
i'd like all of the blurbs
by by wednesday
we're meeting tomorrow but i'd like to
have them on wednesday
and that's let's see representative
schuett
myself
yankovich
represent pearson twice
representative grota and marsh all oh a
report committee report
and representative santa mustafa you've
got a minority report
madam chair question
yes
do you wish to have either your blurbs
in a physical copy or an electronic copy
i'd rather you just emailed it to me
it's easier for me to handle that's
easier for me too thank you
okay
all right then thank you all i'm going
to close the executive session
quite productive
we are resuming at house at 1 15 p.m on
cacr 30.
congratulations
as usual
if i could just have a everybody's
attention for a second
i was over at my mailbox for the first
time in months and i noticed that this
little beauty is in everybody's mailbox
so if you haven't picked yours up
uh
just you're on notice that it's waiting
your your your visit to the
hello to the state house
this state house
the little andy room
you know where we have our mailboxes is
that our little black book a little
black book yeah yeah very useful
publication
welcome back
in the absence of the sponsor
representative bailey could you
introduce this
cacr30
there's some on the table
i wouldn't take any questions if i
thank you madam speaker oh this one's
much louder
this is constitutional amendment
concurrent resolution 30 relating to
officers of the government
and it provides that the elected
positions of inspector general are
created
thank you very much mr representative
bailey
alvin c
there it is okay thank you madam
chairman members of the committee uh my
name is alvin c i live in loudoun i'm
speaking for myself and i'm slightly
opposed to this bill
not greatly but anyway
currently the attorney general does the
inspections or
attorney general elected by the
legislature same as the
just the legislature
and
i think that would take care of the
things one of the concerns i have with
this bill
is if there was election fraud that got
the
uh some of the
uh these inspectors generals elected
would you actually investigate the fraud
that might have elected somebody else if
it hadn't been there
thank you for that and i'll answer any
questions if i can
thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
representative fellows yes i'm just
wondering if you um remember
what the other bill is or
did the com another committee already
hear it or not yet
the bill was heard i'm sorry i do not
remember the number uh it was last week
that i think was last week or the week
before but it's already been heard and
it may have been legislation
administration but i'm not sure it may
have been uh
cacr 60 or something around that
number range but uh i'm sorry i don't
have that number in front of me i didn't
think about that at the time i was
coming in here today
any anyone else
representative scitec
i don't recall any
instance of voter fraud in new hampshire
do you have anything in mind did
anything prompt this
i don't know what prompted this
particular bill
there have always been suggestions that
there have been some
amount of fraud and it also depends on
what you consider to be fraud
one of the things that i think is wrong
but it's not fraud is to allow people
without a state driver's license to vote
in new hampshire
um
that driver's license shows that they're
domiciled somewhere else and and
shouldn't be voting here but that's in
the statutes
representative seitek you may not have
noticed but the attorney general has in
fact prosecuted several people over the
last few years for voting in more than
one state
any other questions comments
representative schmidt
thank you for being here today thank you
madam chair could you just spell your
last name for me
it's spelled s e e
s e e o s e
as i
i see you
thank you very much for testifying we
appreciate having somebody here
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on cacr 30.
seeing now i'll close the public hearing
can you say he's slightly opposed the
bill
that's what he said yes i thought he
said slightly
uh yes representative leckus suggests we
go into executive session
and
moved itl on cacr 30.
i second this is by
representative my luck is seconded by
representative broda do you wish to
speak to your motion
i don't want to cut this short if
there's an interest and people want to
discuss it and i'd be willing to
withdraw the motion if that were the
case but
um
i don't
i don't see that there's a need for this
and there's a bunch of potential
problems with it
and um you know the issue around
secretary of state elections is being
dealt with
there's probably i think there's a
number of bills actually election law
and so i don't see any need for this and
i support itl in it now
thank you representative grota
thank you
i don't see any for this legislation
representative allegra
i i could have offered some commentary
or an answer to uh
representative zytek's question before
but i don't think it was the appropriate
time uh moment but since we're in exec
session i would like to address that now
the the lack of
identifying criminal activity in our
elections is
precisely what prompted this legislation
and let me just give you one example
and i'll just pull this off the top of
my head in 2016 as everybody in this
room knows or most of us should know um
if you uh register on the day of voting
you're supposed to sign an affidavit and
i think it's within 90 days you're
supposed to
complete the conditions of the affidavit
in 2016 there were over 11 000
affidavits filled out for registrants on
election day
over 8 000 of them never completed their
legal duties and it's exactly that kind
of thing that never gets investigated by
the attorney general that prompted this
kind of a bill
and there's lots of other examples i can
give you too but i'm not going to
belabor it if you if you're interested
thank you
senator pearson and then her
thank you madam chair uh as someone
who's written constitutional amendments
and presented them
before the house before
i'd just like to point out because this
comes up all the time on page two our
parts five beyond our boilerplate
they're required to be there by
statute
um
just in case anybody has a curiosity as
to why that
is written the way it is all
constitutional amendments have this
stuck on the bottom of them
that's the first part
um the other thing too is you know
create the creation of these positions
in what we're reading here there's a lot
of there's so many more questions and
answers
as to you know the
how these positions function who they
report to their pay grade the
there's a lot there's a lot missing here
so
while i understand the
the concern i think that that's we've
already got an avenue to address those
concerns
uh and clearly by the number of bills
that have been filed this year we're
we're certainly interested in tweaking
how the attorney general's office
handles those so
i think this just this just muddies
things up tremendously in reference to
the rest of those pending pieces of
legislation
representative horrigan and then uh gold
yep um
first of all
to answer the question that mr c uh
raised um
the driver's license a driver's license
from any state
we belong to a compact with i think
every other state and every other
canadian province so one driver's
license is interchangeable with another
in any of those jurisdictions so that's
why
a driver's license is an acceptable
proof of
proof of proof of identity and um though
not necessarily for address and if your
address has changed then
um you have to provide more
information if there's other ways of
proving what your address is so that's
not actually
voter fraud and the part about the
driver's license is uh
that's a result of that interstate
compact and also um
oh is he
and um the attorney general the
secretary of state are already
investigating election fraud and the
reason they never i'm pretty miss the
reason i never find anything is that
most of these things are either
technical errors like happen in windham
or they're sort of imaginary so
especially
like there's the legendary buses of
voters from massachusetts somehow
nobody's ever gotten a picture of one no
one's ever infiltrated once somehow
there's a certain
so there but somehow that that little
urban myth comes up every two years and
um
the other thing is attorney generals and
secretary state's office they're both uh
like everything else in new hampshire
government they're certainly
far from over funded and probably
underfunded and this inspector general
yeah there's nothing in there about
how we would set a salary or what sort
of assistance he or she could uh could
hire et cetera et cetera and
actually represent horrig and if you
look on line 18 and 19 the rate of
compensation shall be set by the general
court as a matter of law oh yeah during
the but yeah okay you're right
no funding yes
yeah but yes i guess that would be right
that would be provided uh during the
budget process the same way we set the
uh
salaries for just about everybody in
state government except for ourselves
and we even actually set our uh
small
stipends for being members of the county
delegation and statute yep so i guess i
yeah i take back my comment about that
part but still there isn't doesn't seem
to be any specific
way for them to hire uh assistant
inspections general and so forth so
thanks thanks
thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair and that was
specifically where i was going well you
may set the compensation forward there's
nothing there showing the cost of any of
the investigations going forward
um
or what the salary range will be and
if the house so chooses or the senate so
chooses that could be zeroed out and
where do we go from there at no cost and
no money
so that's my concern
thank you any other comments represent
black
yeah i'm not arguing that there's no
voter fraud it's just i don't think this
would be the way to fix it i don't think
it would necessarily fix it and we
certainly have the ability
um either by you know who we uh who we
choose as secretary of state or things
that can be put in statute to fix
whatever we may believe to be a problem
so i don't think we need this thanks
anyone else
yeah i'd like i'd like to mention to
representative horrigan that showing a
driver's license for id once is just
fine it's when you show the same
out-of-state driver's license five or
ten years later that there's a question
of your actual residence
of course of course in that case it
normally would have expired by then so
but yeah yes thank you that's true too
all right any other comments represent
allegro just a quick comment showing a
voter showing a driver's license is
proof of identity it's not proof of
eligibility two separate issues thank
you exactly
all right any other comments questions
seeing none
the motion is itl by representative
laccas
and the clerk can call the role
okay oh i think excuse me representative
perot you had something
no no i was just answering
representatives
yeah okay
thank you
no one did want to say something
nope okay thank you i just wanted to
check
representative rhodes wants to say
something
no i don't
you want to say yes
nobody wants to be on record on this
um
so you said yes right yes uh
all
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes
representative
representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes on the merits
of the bill
uh understood representative bailey yes
representative zara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
please oh that not here yes
uh representative judy
we
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota yes representative
hargan yes
and the chair yes how about 17-0
the motion passes 17-0
does anyone object to consent
seeing none will put it on consent
and we still have a few
a few minutes before our next hearing
party
only
i mean
it just seems like that's a weighty
matter
but fine
i've been asking a lot of thoughtless
questions lately and it's true
still
see
mr
um
uh it's
some correct technical corrections
uh
yes
you
being 145 i will open the
house committee hearing for house bill
committee recognizes representative
carol mcguire
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire representing
merrimack district 29
which is the towns of allenstown epsom
in pittsfield
and house bill 1288 started as
a
catch-up from
last year
when we
added the
[Music]
a number of
directors in the department of
administrative services
and made them unclassified however due
to an oversight and i'm not sure who's
but probably mine we didn't give them a
term we just
said how they would be appointed and
what their duties were
so
uh
i noticed this after we'd passed the
bill
so i'm coming back to set to add in the
um four-year term for these appointed
positions
that's it just the four years
i'm also introducing
non-germane amendment zero zero two h
which is
a number of other
technical changes to
how the department of administrative
services is organized which
i was working on with the with
administrative services when the filing
period ended
and so it has to be an amendment
and
i believe that if you have questions
director arlinghaus would be a better
person to ask than me
i can answer questions on the original
bill but not so much on the amendment
mcguire representative scitec
whose idea was the amendment if you're
was
it was a request of dias i was working
with them
on it when
as i said the filing period ended that's
why it's an amendment you'll notice it's
amendment number two so it i got in
early on that one terrific thank you
see no further questions
oh my apologies no it's okay uh um it
was not you do you have a copy of one of
you have another copy please because i
don't have any
i'm sorry i gave it out
um
a while back okay
thank you
so
one thing
you started out with a bill
that just said how long the terms were
going to be but that's disappeared
no no no this
section one which is the terms stays in
this adds more
between the
essentially between lines five and six
so
maybe i misunderstand on the amendment
it says amend the bill by replacing all
after section one oh after section one
oh okay sorry
and it is not exactly germaine because
it deals with slightly different
sections of law so it has been
separately noticed as a non-german
amendment
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so uh of course commissioners are
appointed for a specific term of office
um and assistant commissioners uh can
you speak to us about
uh their
their position
because obviously to the degree that
they're you know serve at the pleasure
of the governor
then
that's
one possible aspect to the degree they
have a term
like commissioners do they can either be
extended or not
i mean you know reappointed
so can you speak about that a little bit
because
uh who are some of these people
that that are currently in these
positions
for example i know some people like
assistant commissioner
bouchard
who was now an assistant commissioner i
believe
but he's been with the department for a
long time
and to the degree he suddenly is
for a specific appointed term
uh
would he
last last year when we passed the bill
we changed that position and the others
from a classified to an unclassified
position
and
directed
and determined how they would be
appointed we did not put an end date
on their service other than they were
serving at the pleasure of the
commissioner
so
this says you're for four years unless
something funny happens
it
it just gives a
a term there are no limits on
reappointment
thank you
representative grota thank you um
representative
are you answering questions about the
the
bill or the amendment or both
primarily about the bill if it's a
simple question about the amendment i
might be able to answer it but i think
you'd
director arlinghaus is going to be there
okay so he's the better person to answer
the details okay
and i if i understand the bill correctly
all it does is extend
because the commissioner themselves have
serve a four-year term
it would make sense that their
appointments
would also serve for a four-year term so
this bill doesn't seem to be complicated
to me is that right
no the basic bill is very very simple
okay
representative fellows
thank you
so
our most in most of the state agencies
are the division directors
do they have a term of four years or
something different
i don't know the answer to that sorry
representative bailey
thank you
um
you you had just sort of mentioned that
the the term of the terms being talked
about here and the term of the person
appointing them
are both four years
do you need something extra to sort of
say
they run concurrent with the
the commissioners are appointed by one
governor and then go on to serve the
next
so
it's not at all uncommon for people to
be
under the appointing authority
thank you
are there any more questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
representative mcguire
mr arlinghaus
oh
um
apparently it is now
um i'm charlie arlinghaus i'm the
commissioner of administrative services
um we had a bill last year that
created
10 additional among senior management
positions that were not
uh that were classified and will now be
unclassified the
underlying attempt of the bill was to
standardize rather than make it
haphazard the positions in our agency i
had i have seven directors
um most of them over time had become
unclassified one of them hadn't we had a
number of unclassified positions below
the level of director that is a report
to a director
in that bill we standardize things so
directors assistant commissioners deputy
commissioners and the commissioner are
appointed for a term it is for a term of
four years as suggested by 21g when we
reorganized government in the 80s
most directors in state government are
but not all
are appointed for a term a term of four
years a specific term of four years if
it's vacant you fill out the unexpired
term if somebody resigns midway you fill
the unexpired term almost every
assistant commissioner and deputy
commissioner in state government
there are three exceptions that i'm
aware of
are appointed for a term by the governor
and council
specific term these terms are all
outlined in the red book
most of most of our assistant
commissioners etc we have one assistant
and one deputy it's just sort of an
oddity of history
um and directors were appointed for a
term in the drafting of the bill a year
ago
in re-writing a paragraph they
accidentally left out
these words each of whom shall serve a
term of four years so there are people
today who were appointed for a term of
four years that if they were reappointed
tomorrow
actually have one holdover would not be
appointed for a term and would
theoretically
serve indefinitely
um which is you know good for them but
probably not exactly what we're doing so
it's it's merely a drafting year it's
quite literally a drafting error that
doesn't really affect um almost any
position the amendment i would like to
talk you through
does things that i think are also um
cleanup and representative mcguire was
was kind enough to sponsor it
some of them are going to seem silly to
you but important to the people who
asked for them but um there are four
things this does the first thing is it
takes financial data management which is
one of our seven divisions it is the
division
fdm it's typically called that manages
the state's computer system that is to
say the state enterprise computer system
that does financials that does budgets
that does
payroll that does hris
and it's not a financial management
system when the division was created in
the 80s it was an attempt to say instead
of doing our books by hand on paper we
need to do them on a computer
which is a big deal back in the 80s
today people apparently use computers
for lots of things
in fact more things than i use computers
for
but so what they do is not financial
data management but that's their name
this doesn't affect anything
it doesn't change what they do
but
that group of people is like well you
know we're not really financial data
management we we manage the enterprise
operation it's not it's really
misleading and
i made a promise once that if you come
up with a name and we have a cleanup
bill
you can call it as long as it's not
obscene
whatever you would like
and they came up with something that
wasn't obscene and it's just enterprise
operations management
most of the text of the amendment finds
the places where those words occur
and emphasizes them and then this
modernizes the language about what they
do
it doesn't really affect anything in
particular
there are a couple of other things that
we do there is a there's a when we make
changes to the state's classification
system usually through the division of
personnel
there's language that requires them to
consult with the personal personnel
system task force
it occurs in two places in statute there
isn't such a thing
there is not a personnel system task
force there was once as a result of
collective bargaining um almost 20 years
ago i think and it was created in the in
the cba and it expired and it goes away
so we have to consult them but they're
not a thing
what it really means is that we can't
make changes willy-nilly and are meant
to consult stakeholders which is
basically you know hr
management unions etc and so
this is a tweak
uh where we just instead of saying
personnel system task force
a stakeholders group overseen by the
director personnel which is by the way
what we which is what we're doing and
what a personal system task force would
be it just makes it clear and there's
not this weird language that's hanging
out as an orphan would we ordinarily do
this as a bill no but because we're
doing some other quote unquote cleanup
or significant effect on anything
um
the thing that does have a significant
effect on anything or or is more
i think of this cleanup but we can talk
about
is um
the bureau of education and training is
the is the employee education portion of
the division of personnel that exists
today
um their job is to do uh is to do very
specific training across state
government
um in modern practices they do
managerial training they do say
supervisory training
um they run a certified public manager
program that every state has that we
this is where ours exists and any other
thing that that the state enterprise
needs sort of
training of employees
in the past that
bureau
has been funded
roughly speaking about 50 general funds
and 50 from charges in the most recent
budget there were a decision to make
cuts
and
one of the things that the state
considered an early phase was just
cutting it entirely instead the
governor's office decided and the
legislature ended up agreeing with um
just eliminating all the general funds
from that agency and saying you got a
quote unquote eat what you kill
um that is to say everything has to be
self-supporting and based on tuition
charges
in the past because of timing issues
there was a twenty thousand dollar
holdover you can carry forward twenty
thousand dollars of funds
um to to pay for your operations because
obviously
um nobody runs an operation where every
month is a standalone
and so when june 30th comes on july 1st
you have no money we had general funds
so it didn't matter much the decision
here was to change that number just to
essentially update it to say a hundred
thousand dollars so we collect tuition
payments
and then we use those tuition payments
to fund that operation to fund the
classes to fund the personnel and this
merely says that you can carry
carry forward at the end of the fiscal
year so that instead of that money
lapsing it's essentially a non-lapsing
fund
it's something we do in the budget all
the time right you create all kinds of
non-lapsing funds where the money
doesn't go away at the end and
admittedly you know we fund state
government through a through a
significant lapse at the end of the year
which is a you know not something you
see in the private sector because it's
because we're a government not a not a
business um
there are cases where you make the
entire fund non-lapsing what we did here
sort of split the baby rather than
making the entire fun non-lapsing and
just saying they're all tuition payments
just use them for tuition and keep going
like that maybe the healthcare fund
would be
we just cap it at 100 000. so why do we
do that and not make it non-lapsing
because it currently exists as 20 and
this seemed like
a less revolutionary change
just merely to fund that anyway so
that's the amendment i think of it as
cleanup with that one exception you
might want to talk about
representative grota and then lucas
thank you mr earlinghouse currently
if you have more than twenty thousand
dollars in your revolving fund at the
end of the year
where does that money go it lapses
okay but it goes so it goes back lapses
to the general fund yeah right okay
follow-up so under the underneath
with this amendment
the
maximum allowed that would be
held in your fund would be a hundred
thousand yes and excess of that would go
back to the general fund it would okay
promise last question
how much money do you generally have
left over at the end of the year
somewhere between zero over the last uh
let's say six or seven years somewhere
between zero and forty
thousand dollars yes okay thank you very
much
representative lekkas
thank you um
taking a look at at part two um um
uh no
starting line eight page one
there's that whole section there where
um
it's uh you know talking about what the
director of enterprise operations
management's responsible for and i look
at the existing
statute and the amendment
and it looks like it's sort of organized
maybe some rewording maybe a little
expansion can you mean
your view as to what the general purpose
of this section is
the changes
um statute for the for the function of
directors or divisions
um
tends to be um a little bit vague
and there's an argument that people
can make that it's meaningless which i
think is an exaggeration
but that um what they do is what needs
to be done
in in the general you know thing that
the thing that they're doing so on
personnel you you know when something
comes up we have to administer federal
feds have new law fmla we look we have
to administer fmla that's a personnel
function they have to do it whether the
law has those words in it or not
um
[Music]
alex stone is the current head of this
division and he rewrote it to synopsize
what they do if i'm honest there was an
early draft that was about six pages
and i said can we cut this to maybe 200
words and just you know hit the high
points and
this won't change anything that they do
and i mean basically what they do today
is they manage the state's computer new
hampshire first the state enterprise
system
in a way that is necessary for the
functions of the executive branch
and the other members of the executive
branch determine what needs to be done
and when they have problems and when it
happens you know liquor is doing a brand
new a big new
computer system at liquor and
regardless of what we think we have to
help with that because they have to talk
to each other they have to mesh
and i'm never going to write in here
we need to mesh with liquor if liquor
has a project or we need to mesh with d
arrays new rim system of dras rims has a
project whatever is in there
it's meant to be a sort of generic
high-level description of of kind of
what they do okay and that is enough all
right thank you and thank you for uh
cutting
it down from six pages yeah i thought
that would be good quick follow-up if i
may
uh this is on um on the education fund
how much is being spent overall
on uh training within uh diaz
oh geez i should know that off the top
of my head and i don't i'm gonna
i'm gonna use the number um
big big ballpark number about a half a
million dollars a year um we don't spend
i'm sorry in the bureau of education and
training
there are occasionally departments which
run their own hhs has its own program
which meshes in some areas with ours and
is completely separate in some areas i
think they call it oads
and
an agency will have its own program you
know safety will have some very specific
programs to safety some of them we're
involved in some of them were not our
mandate broadly writ is to do
employee training that's more
generalized our biggest literature
program which which um
which every state has
it's um the certified public manager is
essentially modern personnel i just
didn't hear things oh that's okay um and
then uh essentials of state supervision
which is basically to
to take employees who come in there
periodically been mandates that every
supervisor take that in state the state
system
which is to explain
basically how things differ here you
know we're we're unionized and if you're
coming from a non-unionized place you
have to take that into account
there are restrictions on their
different ethics rules you know there's
a there's a functional essentially a
gift ban here whereas a lot of people
might have if you didn't come from the
state you might have come from an area
where somebody wants to take you out to
lunch that's okay
you work for the state nobody gets to
take you out to lunch ever
and um
and all of those kind of things and sort
of walk through that okay thank you i
just wanted to get a feel for the size
of it
representative schmidt
thank you thank you madam chair
so commissioner uh
as you know and uh and i have a little
bit of knowledge as a member of the
joint committee on employee
classification on which
representative scitec and i have served
now for a decade anyway
here a little bit longer than i
so we have a little bit of our toes in
the water more than some of our
committee colleagues do uh and and i've
come to know that the governor has some
leeway in order in order for him uh and
his
staff to manage
the executive branch uh
they're not locked in uh to what
everything the the statute may say
descriptively and so forth and you've
already talked about this a little bit
uh but maybe you could give us just a
little bit more information because i
think you've said several times and it's
important for me to know anyway uh that
that most of what we're doing is is
adapting language to what is actually
being done rather than changing things
we're just calling it something
different or
uh
maybe the language is just very outmoded
and it's time to get closer to reality
uh so to the degree that we're just
and
as you know sometimes a statute will say
something such and such a program such
as such a company such and such an
address or whatever
the moment that changes the statute is
wrong and needs to be changed to reflect
the reality or else to take that
specificity out entirely um and so how
much of what we're talking about today
is along the lines of
getting closer to
what is done or getting away from being
specific when it doesn't serve the
purpose of clarity or reflecting what's
actually going on
thank you
um thank you there are two purposes of
of statute and well
there's statutes on every department
every agency state government and they
talk about what that agency is for and
supposed to do
there are there the language in that
statute that requires you to do certain
things you must produce this you must do
this you must regulate this you must do
rules on that those are things that you
absolutely unequivocally have to do you
can't not do those things if it's
outlined if it's prescriptive you must
do all of those things
that does not stop the governor for
example from assigning tasks to an
agency um that aren't specifically
spelled out yeah i'm sorry i need
someone to do this is going to be you
and and you end up doing that presuming
that's um also allowed by law and
legitimate under law
in addition to that um in the the great
reorganization of state government of
the mid-80s um they created the language
which resides in 21g
um which is sort of a catch-all statute
if you if you're overly interested in
statutes um it's a catch-all statute it
includes stuff in the end and at the end
there's stuff about procurement and this
stuff about how we organize state
government but one of the things it says
is that any
any agency head think commissioner um
depending on the agency
may assign tasks or organize
his or her staff the way he or she wants
and that is to say if you need something
done
there are some things that have to be
done in certain areas and there are
other things that your agency just has
to get them done and you work with the
staff along those level along that level
to get it done in the unclassified
workforce
there is a
because it's a different thing right
it's um there's a little bit more
flexibility in that
it's almost every sjd the job
description for an employee for the
classified system has language in it
about other duties as assigned
it's a language that allows some
flexibility but it's designed not to be
abused
with the unclassified i don't say
unclassified they're designed to be
abused but they're designed to be more
flexible
and the governor has a great deal of
authority over them although you know
unusually among states that um
you know just because
just because one governor appoints you
doesn't mean your term expires at the
end typically many many many employees
um cross over those lines particularly
at the more senior levels not for lots
of years but for a few
thank you
representative fellows
i just want to say in terms of the
the money for training that i mean i
totally support what you're doing for
that i just a comment that i think that
nor there's never enough money for
training of personnel and i think that's
one of the reasons that we have
a lot of turnover and it's hard to fill
positions but moving on from that i
agree to get back to um
the
changing the
the division name
uh
what happens
i know what financial management is
and
i'm a little
do you have
the the title that it exists now for the
division is financial data management is
there another division that is financial
management because managing the data for
finance is different than
than you know being an accountant or
controller or something like that can
you
so this
it's a good question the states the
state's financial
controls if you will
are organized in in a multiple in a
couple of areas one is one is the the
budget office which is headed by the
assistant commissioner joe bouchard if
people want names
and that consists of business
supervisors who interact with every
agency and manage the gnc process the
legislative fiscal process the budgeting
process
and the and the compliance and
development of all of those functions so
you have a group of people who are
business supervisors who interact that's
actually is that is that um lba or is
that admin server no that's us okay so
lba just manages the legislature asking
us questions about whether we're doing
our job
um i don't mean that quite literally we
obviously have a very strong
relationship and you know joe talks to
mike kane weekly almost and we talked to
them a lot but
the lba will report to you on whether
we're doing a good job or not but um the
business of managing the executive
branch
falls to joe and his staff it's actually
the oldest area of the department the
the department was created as a as an
office of the comptroller with
three business supervisors in it in 1931
when there was a sense on the
legislature's part that um
agencies weren't managing rights so you
know there wasn't a budget per se and
people agencies would spend what they
were given and then three quarters of
the way through the year they'd run out
and they'd come back and go can we have
some more
and somebody decided that wasn't a great
way to run a railroad and um
um and so they changed it so that's the
oldest area of the department at some
point uh during the the first 20 years
it evolved where they created took one
of the business supervisors there were
more at that point and made him or her
it was a hymn at the time
the chief accountant for the state
and that position eventually became
called comptroller and the head of the
agency stopped being comptroller
and often not with no accounting
practice
background and became commissioner which
is good because i'm not a cpa
um
so we have a budget division that
manages from a budget standpoint they're
very budget-oriented and very and you
know if you know joe bouchard you know
the state's in very good hands with him
but he's not an accountant either he's a
budget guy which is different
the state's chief accounting officer is
the state's comptroller or controller
depending on how you want to pronounce
it
i said that for representative scitec
and it's the division of accounting
services they are the accountants they
do pre-audits on funds
funds to make sure you have money to
spend they produce the state's annual
financial reports that is the accounting
control function in theory
financial data management when it was
just financial data
was created to support those two units
and to provide them
administrative backup and to transition
to a computer system we were producing
um annual financial reports really
really really really slow and late
and um like wicked late like a year year
and a half after the fiscal year ended
and um
and one of the things that that people
saw at the time is let's have a computer
um i think literally it was the
gov current governor's father who who
created this division
um
over time though that evolved because
the way
uh corporations any large enterprise
runs is with a computer system that's
typically called an enterprise system
oracle is big ours happens to be run by
infor and that that um
that thing is managed by one agent one
division one group of people one group
of 32 people in this particular case um
and it that unit happens to be called
financial data management but they don't
just do financial data they do the
budget system which is a separate module
they do the purchasing systems which are
separate modules the p card system which
is a separate module
um and they do the the the payroll
system which is i think literally the
most important thing we do i'll get
fired if we don't get a paycheck out um
and uh i don't want to say anything else
is okay but that's a big thing um and
the hr system would through the system
of hiring and et cetera et cetera
and so it's a giant enterprise
which isn't really financial data it's
it's an enterprise system when you buy
the when you buy the software so to
speak which tends to cost 30 or 40
million dollars um you're buying an
enterprise system and so so that's why
they in the interest of uh false
advertising that's why they call it that
um yeah are are these people that are
that are currently in the
division of financial data management
that we want to change the name to are
those i.t people yes
so
why don't we call it i.t like why don't
we call it like admin services i.t
department it's an option right um it's
uh there's a department of
there is a department an i.t department
state right dyt
and i think they didn't want to pick
that because dyt's in charge of just all
i.t with this one notable exception the
one area of i.t that is not currently in
doit and under under dennis's grip so to
speak is uh is this function and because
they don't do all i.t
so we have a relationship as a
department with the oit sue luba happens
to be our contact um who's wonderful but
um we do a lot of i.t work but the
the big enterprise software package
that that is the uh nerve system of the
operation of state government is managed
by this group of people and it's not
financial
it's the enterprise system
and and and they believe as people who
work in this field that
that name
uh
means something to people
interacting with them they're like oh
that's what you do
one more
followed by representative goalie
so so i i have you given any thought to
the fact that while that title makes a
lot of sense to the people that are in
that division that for people outside of
that or maybe the public that something
that's called i t might might make more
sense to them
is it seems to me that enterprise
operations management is something that
could go out of date too so i think
everything could go out of date
that's at the end of what i'm going to
say
i'd like to say that
you know 40 years ago when i was working
in a large corporation we had enterprise
software and everybody knew what it
meant it's a term of art in large
organizations
see i didn't even know that so that's
good
i know what you're saying though and i
hear you
representative
goalie thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question today um i'm just
going back to
the amendment page two when we're
changing line nine
changing the recommendations of the
personnel system task force to a
stakeholders group
could you
tell me because i'm looking for a
definition what is the personnel system
task force
well that's why i'm making the change
because it's not defined it doesn't
exist and there's no such thing
so we're so weird this happens to come
up because we're looking at
um
we're looking at making changes of the
personnel system the classification
system and we have you know we have
regular meetings with um
with hr with uh with various unions and
um
people around state government and
there's no actual personnel system task
force so we had this internal discussion
at one point where somebody said well
what what is it
it's not defined anywhere what are we
supposed to do we have to consult them
but they're not a thing
so there's one argument that says well
then you if they're not a thing then you
don't really have to consult them
because you can't consult something that
doesn't exist
on the other hand
we tried to
i spent some time with
um
you know the written rsas and they have
language change and they have the sort
of amendment history at the bottom
to try to figure out where did the
language come from and what did it mean
it dates back almost certainly to a to a
collective bargaining agreement in i
believe 2007
don't hold me to the date
where they created a system to write a
report and make a recommendation it
didn't do anything
but it was it was just for the purposes
of that report occasionally stuff gets
gets stuck into law as an orphan
and and doesn't exist and so we thought
clean up the orphan so we considered two
options here one was just to actually
delete the language so that
it's not something we have to do
on the other hand you can't really make
changes to something complicated and
particularly
you know the state personnel system you
just can't without doing a lot of
consultation so we thought what exactly
are we doing when we do consultation
well we we consult stakeholders we
consult people you know people who have
a say and that's and that's management
and that's unions and that's employees
and that's hr and it's
and it's um and that's who you talk to
and so we thought why don't we just
write it down that way and so we wrote
it down that way
i follow it
recognize her follow-up
and that's
my next question is because that's still
very vague just saying hey stakeholders
group there's nobody listed as to
what group of stakeholders or if there's
numerous groups that are involved that
they are all participating or one or two
groups out of the four are participating
it's very vague
in that wording as well and that's just
my concern going there as well no it's a
it it's a really good point the question
is how do you how do you get um how do
you get specific and and yet allow some
flexibility um
as you make changes to any piece of the
system you're going to make changes to
um
not everybody's going to be involved in
everything right like if you're making
changes at
the things that only impact let's just
say um
troopers of the department of safety
there's some
unions you will consult and others you
won't so you know do we consult with as
the state has a proliferation of unions
i think we're up to don't hold me to
this i think 13 at this point
um in terms of the
negotiating but we're not going to
consult all 13 on everything we do i
mean typically the sea is almost always
involved because their reach is broader
and so you might not consult
you know troopers on things that don't
affect troopers or the you would only
consult troopers and things that only
affect troopers
and um
you know do you need a cross-section of
hr to address you know this issue or do
you not and so the idea is to um
you know no change is going to be made
that isn't going to go to the
legislature and isn't going to go to you
know the governor or
or policymakers as opposed to
administrators
um and and they can address whether
we've encompassed stakeholders or not
but if i'm honest we couldn't think of a
good definition of stakeholder
stakeholder implies that
you need to be able to make a straight
face argument that you have consulted
with the people who have a stake in this
and you can't leave anyone out
and to be overly prescriptive just
leads you down weird paths
thank you
representative pearson
i'm going to bounce off what
representative goalie said in the sense
of
who determines who the stakeholders are
under this theoretically um based on the
language it would be the director
personnel i mean the the language says
a stakeholder group overseen by the
director of personnel the the
reason for that language is actually to
say that
um it is it is she who would convene
that laurie rudis is our current
director personnel it's she who would
convene them and she who who would uh
organize the meeting would in theory run
the meeting because somebody has to run
the meeting
and she would decide who's in it
other representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so a commissioner uh on line 16
oops
uh
it's the reference to 541a it's line 11.
um
shall not be considered rule subject to
541a is that a change
that um that's that's not a change
that's currently in the um
in the statute i'm trying to find it on
my i have the wrong version but no i
i'll accept your word on it yeah it's
just that you know i know
representative mcguire and i are on on
are on gel car and there are some things
that are exempt to 541a because you have
to be more flexible than 541a which is
pretty time consuming and it's so if
it's not a change that's not a problem
now my understanding is that
classification system itself has been um
has been exempt from rules going back to
you know
governor murphy
are there any more questions for the
commissioner
seeing them we thank you for your
testimony thank you for having me
thank you are there any other members
from the public that wish to testify for
house bill 1288
scene none i will close the public
hearing thank you
you
thank you madam chair for the record
representative jeff goalie representing
hillsborough district 8 manchester's
ward 1
here today to introduce house bill 1294
an act requiring the commission of
demographic trends to consider data on
race and ethnicity for the purpose of
increasing racial and ethnic diversity
in new hampshire
with that being said i will take no
questions and i will take my seat after
i fill out a pink card
thank you representative goalie
i call roy schweiker
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee i'm roy schweiker from concord
i oppose this bill
i think that
anyone
would know that right now the people
that are moving into new hampshire are
more diverse on average than the people
that already live here
i don't see any problem with that i
think whoever wants to live in new
hampshire should be equally entitled to
and that's why i'm opposed to this bill
i think that if the ku klux klan showed
up and said we should encourage more
white people to move to new hampshire
because you know we're becoming more
diverse i would say that would be racist
it should not be allowed it should not
be in the law
and i'm going to say the equal thing
about this bill
saying we should have a requirement that
the state become more diverse that
should not be a state policy that's
equally racist
so that's why i'm opposed to this bill
while i'm here i would like to say
a couple of things
one thing is
right now i think if you ask the state
demographer
the only group that is moving out of new
hampshire faster than they're moving in
are the elderly
and
so if the state demographer is supposed
to try and figure out what's happening
maybe we should figure out why the
elderly are moving out faster than
they're moving in even though
the college educated young people who
are always griping about in fact moving
in faster than they leave
and the second thing is that
right now the statute says that
we should plan for growth in new
hampshire i don't know how many of you
people
are you know
believers in climate change are big on
climate change
but i think that
it's thought that over time
the world's populations have stabilized
and therefore any policy that
demands continued growth
is contrary to the goals of
dealing with climate change i think that
we've discovered that the people who
live here in effect are not growing but
shrinking
and therefore we should try and have a
state policy that allows
the state to thrive without continued
growth because we do not ultimately want
the state of new hampshire to look like
downtown tokyo thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from the committee
representative grota
thank you mr schreiker
one of the
issues that new hampshire is dealing
with is the
need for younger people to
come to new hampshire because we are
actually an older
state to fill the positions that are
available to um for
our employers
and i'm wondering how you would feel if
we amended the bill to
look at it from a standpoint of
younger people
moving to new hampshire rather than or
the extension of younger people in new
hampshire rather than diversity factor
i would be equally opposed to that
i think that once again there's a group
of people that is advocating we need
more younger people in the state i think
that's equally as bad as saying we need
more white people in the state
i think that if you want to say we need
more workers in the state that may or
may not be true because
you know some jobs are getting automated
at the same time that we're needing more
being done
i volunteer with a group that helps
people who are unemployed find jobs
nearly everybody in this group is in
their 50s because right now we have
very severe age discrimination in the
state
in terms of hiring older people
i mean i know a woman who
has been patronizing restaurants for
years
she came upon some hard times she's
trying to find a job as a restaurant
hostess she cannot get an interview for
a restaurant hostess presumably because
of her age because
you know one might think she had the
right appearance and decorum to be a
hostess in these restaurants she
patronizes
so i think that once again saying we
need more young people to fill the jobs
we need to look at
what are the barriers why are not
older people being hired for these jobs
and having to leave the state thank you
thank you other questions
representative schmidt
thank you ma'am sure
so uh
what is the current status of this
so-called state demographer this
committee has gone back and forth over
the years with several bills with regard
to demographer which i think we if we
don't have one currently we desperately
need one because
every time i've heard a presentation by
people like peter francis who was one of
the very noted
demographers in new hampshire who's now
semi-retired i believe
uh it indicates we don't have a very
good handle on
the demographic trends and so forth that
are important to understand i i heard
you say you don't you don't like the
idea of studying with with regard to
having a target population i think i
agree with you on that
but where are we with regard to state
demographer at the moment
well i guess i'm not
i guess i'm not really qualified to
answer that question my understanding is
of mr johnson who does this sort of work
but i don't know he has an official
position or not and once again i
like you i
don't think that studies are necessarily
bad but i think that having the state
come forward and say we need more young
people or we need more diverse people
that's a mistake we should study you
know like you say what the trends are
and
that's what's important rather than
the
state legislature deciding in advance
who we need to live in the state
thank you
other questions
thank you for your testimony
very much appreciate it
is there any other member of the public
that wishes to testify on house bill
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing
and moving into executive session
representative rhodes has a motion
thank you madam chairman
i would like to make a motion to itl
health spill 1294.
okay
motion is itl met by representative
rhodes seconded by representative
fellows
do you care to speak to your motion
thank you madam chairman
i
i i find that there are several concerns
that i have with this bill um one
to start with b how exactly are we to
collect this data
um
who and what would establish what the
net migration goal would be
and
i i just i just disagree with the bill
thank you very much
representative fellows you should speak
to your second
um yes i my understanding is that the
state does not have a demographer that
there was um the position was created
maybe three years ago and it's never
been filled
and
i i think i think demographic data is
really important i don't i haven't read
this entire statute so i don't know what
else that the commission is supposed to
be doing
but i well i think that
you know this
understanding
who we are
in the state
understanding where different population
groups exist in the state and
and trends of migration
within the from north country and south
korea i think those are all really
important things to study
but
just adding picking out the the racial
and ethnic identity i don't think
contributes
to the
study without these words in here
there's nothing to prevent them from
looking at that
and the other thing
my experience with data
is
trying to identify who is in different
racial groups and ethnic groups is very
difficult task
and becoming increasingly more difficult
so that's all i have yes thank you i'd
also like to mention that i was looking
to see what's in the statute
and all of rsa4-c
has been repealed
so there is no
such commission to
amend it may have been moved
representative horrigan well that was
what i was going to say and it was
repealed just last year but it does seem
like uh
something
something went a bit of rye in the
drafting process if they failed to uh
well it was the office of strategic
initiative which was moved so possibly
the demographic office is somewhere else
but i don't know where yeah but
follow up yeah as you correctly said the
whole rsa has been wiped off with the
book there's nothing but a little stub
saying it's been
deleted so that's uh
that's a pretty major technical problem
how it happened i'm not sure although
perhaps the
effective date of the provision which
seems to be in the budget trailer bill
but i'm not sure perhaps the effective
date
this was after the filing window it was
part of the
consolidation of the department of
energy so it was an hb2 but i don't know
where they would have put this
commission yeah it's possible to
represent
it sounds like resident gallagher may
have made his
may have come in during it during the
filing period window during which he
submitted his lsr may have like happened
before
it got wiped off officially got wiped
off the books but that
does seem like a rather strange strange
mishap for his lsr you think
any other comments questions
yeah yes representative yes
it is
it is clearly even they talk about
demographic
but it's clearly a racist bill
clearly so no question about it
to check how many uh
to consider racial ethnic here in new
hampshire i think israel is his bill
and we don't need that
in new hampshire enough is enough
when i see those bills
i feel it in my heart
i don't have a place here in new
hampshire
i don't want to talk more about it but
uh it's really helpful
it's really hurtful for me when i see
those bills
because we can do more
than that here in new hampshire than
those stupid bill
because uh less
we fought for race so many times
i don't see the reason why to bring a
bill like that here in new hampshire
so again
those bills make me feel
i don't belong here
even i i am an american citizen
thank you
any other comments
representative bailey
thank you madam
um
disquieting as that is
just the uh just the notion that the
state government would have a migration
goal as to how many people should or
should not move into here or
shocking i think that's unsettling in
itself never mind the racial and ethnic
makeup of it
yes it is
we don't get to have a goal as a state
government for how many people live here
or
we should certainly look up to where
that commission went
and find out what its goals are that
sounds kind of uh
thank you object
and pearson thank you to bounce off that
historically
looking back in the last 60 years
any attempt to artificially do any of
this stuff has always ended in disaster
so the state of new hampshire should
just develop
as it has naturally as a free state of
people that that can come and go as they
choose and when you start trying to
force
things
as we've seen historically it it just
does not work so
the
and i think that this this attempt here
completely ignores
the past 60 years of of these attempts
yes representative schmidt
representative allegro
thank you um
when i first looked at this bill i
i thought i must be misunderstanding
something
um but i hear the comments from the rest
of the committee members who i'm
in total agreement with and i just
find a need to go on the record to say
that
choosing the people who you feel are
most desirable to move into the state is
an abhorrent practice and i can't
support this bill thank you
why are we shooting this corpse
good question i think the state should
just continue to make itself attractive
all right representative
if you'd like madam chair i can contact
um
ken gallagher
at the office of initiative of
strategic initiatives
because he is involved he is the um
director i believe of the state data
center that collects all this
information
and they seem to collect it from
different parts of the um
of the state such as the planning
commissions in different counties so if
you'd like i can ask that question to
him and i'll report to the committee
thank you that would be very helpful we
would like to know where that commission
went
we'll do okay any other comments
representative marsh uh madam chair i
looked it up and the rsa4c was repealed
by section 189 of the budget
yep
okay
anyone else
representative schmidt
uh thank you madam chair so uh i i i
share the sentiments that have been
expressed up to this point i think that
our job is to make this the best state
we can people will come or go based on
lots of different reasons uh
but we should not be trying to steer
uh that phenomenon we should just be the
state we are
and try to help our our people be as
well educated and well prepared to be
citizens as we can
and uh
that's the story of america so
uh let's let's stick with what uh what
we really should be about and not
trying to change it around
okay
yes representative
yes i don't think we
we can ignore
our motto here in new hampshire live
free or die
and that's the same way
where i come from in haiti
live
live free for thy
mean and french
i choose
to live free
to die for my freedom
thank you very much for that information
other comments questions
okay seeing not represents like that guy
if somebody's going by the witness table
turn off their microphone
all right
thank you anyway
all right so any other comments
questions
seeing none the motion is itl on house
bill 1294 and the clerk call the roll
representative
yes yes sir swell
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative jacob
yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes represent
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso
yes representative goalie
yes
representative judy
for this bill is yes not we is yes
uh okay representative schmidt yes
representative marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota
yes
representative hargan yes
the chair yes
sounds like 18 to zero
if you don't mind
i thank you very much all of you here
to vote yes
for itl
because i am a human being like
everybody else here in new hampshire
thank you god bless you
fair enough fair enough
and absolutely
is there any objection to consent
okay seeing none will go on consent
and we have a few minutes before our
next hearing at three o'clock
when i get questions
fair enough
various groups of folks that have come
from somewhere so uh yeah i just think
that that might
that's some sort of a feel-good thing
make many of us
thank you
did you do
because we
i'm started here to try to answer the
question of what are we going to
discover
you
all right good afternoon i'm opening the
hearing on house bill 1314
and i call representative graham the
sponsor
um
whoa
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record i'm
representative john graham hillsborough
district 7 which is the town of bedford
you have before you a very simple bill
to study
the way that
the new hampshire state veterans
home is managed
this is not the first time
that we've looked at this eight years
ago
we took a quick look at it
i've given you the report of that study
committee
but what i'd like to really focus on is
that we need to look at how
in the 21st century
our our home for our most vulnerable
veterans is managed
the board of managers is specified in
law who it is three of them
are on it because they win
an election whether it's the american
legion vfw
disabled american veterans and in all
honesty i served on it for a year as the
head of the state
american legion
there isn't the others are
most of them are nominated by their
uh service organization like the
american legion or the vfw can nominate
somebody that does have to be
confirmed by uh governor and council
there is no requirement
that there be any kind of medical
background
nursing home background long care
long-term care knowledge of any of these
people
in the statute
now i know that one of the members of
the board right now is a retired nurse
but that's
hit or miss it's not a requirement
and when we look at what happened
to the state to the south of us and what
unfortunately happened
in many of the nursing homes around
our state i think that it is time that
we look at
if we don't do away with the board of
managers at least what some of the
qualifications for some of the
members that are confirmed by governor
and council should be
at least some of them should have some
kind of background i'll be honest when i
served on it for one year
the first few meetings i've trying to
figure out what all the reports that
were given to us about infection rates
and everything else were i'm a history
major
so it was kind of hard
so i think that that needs to be a hard
look
the committee
may elect to leave it that way i know a
lot of veterans will say oh it's running
well
but does that preclude us from looking
at what is best
this is a quasi-state agency
all of the people from the commandant on
down
are state employees
we fund
this um
the the home with state and federal
funds through the va
so i think it's time to look at it
and
i think there is also going to be a need
longer term and this was something that
the last study committee also pointed
out that perhaps
perhaps there should be a legislative
oversight committee on the home if you
leave it as a standalone
agency
i'm not going to try to answer any
questions on
what i think the study should find
but i will try to answer questions about
why i brought it forward at this time
madam chair thank you
thank you representative lackas
thank you um i guess the question is
are you
asking for this because you see
structural problems with how it's run or
because you believe there are are
particular problems there i i think it's
for me it's more systemic and structural
than the the other like when i mentioned
that
no requirement for any kind of expertise
in in running the place
right now they just went through the
board of managers hires and fires the
commandant that the head of the
new hampshire veterans home doesn't go
to government council it's there in
their in their hands they just went
through the process of hiring the
current commandants replacement
i don't there is some requirements for
that but
i think that it would be better served
if we treated it and now i am getting
into why i brought it forward
if we looked at it more as a state
agency and not as a
bailiwick for the veteran service
organizations okay thank you
representative goalie and then
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative graham for being here and
taking questions
i look at this
2014 report and i look at
the bill you're bringing before us
and on line 15 of your bill
should new hampshire veterans home be
certified by the department of health
and human services
and i look at the report
and it says an interim study research
the pros and cons of certification
through the department of health and
human services
was that done after this report was
written
to the best of my knowledge now
it may have been but i have no personal
knowledge of whether that was done or
not and there is another problem that if
we leave it as a state agency whether
another state agency can oversee
that
you you all understand that better than
i do
up
and then one last question i see you
have uh
recommendations about an oversight
committee
and i see in the report
item number 13 is that an oversight
committee be established to oversee the
new hampshire veterans home correct that
hasn't been done that has not been done
that would take legislation to do that
and
i have not seen that since i came back
in 16.
thank you
person pearson thank you madam chair
representative graham as you're well
aware
with your tenure here at this
legislature we have over 200
committees and commissions
is there an existing
committee or commission
that this could be assigned to rather
than creating a new one
not to the best of my knowledge no there
is a
state veterans advisory
committee that that meets but it does
not have the same
powers that a legislative study
commission or committee excuse me not
commission committee would have to to
take testimony and bring forth
legislation
in the following
term representative goalie
thank you madam chair and just one more
quick question going on that note as we
know how many study committees the
legislature does entail
um we have a report in front of us with
recommendations
that was done back in 2014
what's to say that this committee does
the same thing files a report with these
same recommendations and we're at the
same point five years from now
you have no guarantee on anything that
happens from one legislature to the next
um
personally i think that the ball was
dropped in in 15 and 16 based on the
people who were on that study committee
that they did not bring forward
legislation to try to do any of the
recommendations
but i can't guarantee that any of us
will be here
in 2023 to to follow up even if this
committee had all kinds of
recommendations
any others
i have a question representative graham
since there was a study committee
you know six years ago why don't we just
dust off those recommendations and issue
the same report
you can do that if you want madam chair
but um i i still think that
the first thing that i'm i'm asking that
that be looked at the
the powers and duties of the board of
managers still needs to be looked at the
rest
they may just go with what was there
before um and in all honesty
if i was gonna
don't ask me to chair it but if i was to
chair the study
i probably would do that
and try to get the the background
that was done at that point on
things like the legislative oversight
committee
representative pearson
thank you madam chair
looking back at the work done in 2014
item or number 12 here on the
recommendation list pretty much paved a
road here says that all proposed
legislative legislation relative to this
be assigned to state federal relations
and veteran affairs committee
so they well you know you'll have to
take that up with the speaker
[Laughter]
all right any other questions for
representative graham
seeing none thank you thank you madam
chair and committee
and i call kevin grady
so far this is the first
committee i don't believe so but i'll
check
thank you madam chair ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is kevin grady i'm a
25-year air force veteran
23-year veteran of the town of hooksett
today i'm here representing the state
veterans advisory committee
for those of you unfamiliar with what we
do we are chartered by state rsa to come
in and tell you what the veterans of new
hampshire think about
bills and and to provide services in
other areas and we're kind of an
information conduit a veteran has a
problem somebody in our group knows how
to solve it essentially
one of the things that we do is we
review all the legislation that's going
to come forward and then we take a
position on those issues that have what
we think is a veteran impact and
to be honest we can either support
oppose or elect to follow a bill where i
would just sit like a fly on the wall
and report back to our committee what uh
what was said
i was a little surprised on this one
because i thought we would probably
follow it but i have to tell you that
our members were were across the board
pretty well opposed to this legislation
their thought process is that the board
of managers as it's currently
constructed
reflects sort of the original view of
the place when it was called the
soldiers home way back in the day in
that that veterans should be the large
majority of the folks the representative
graham's point about having some
expertise on the board of managers
dealing with nursing homes and those
kind of things is well taken and i think
you know we i know enough people on that
board and are that we can certainly make
that recommendation to them as members
uh get out and move on that they look
for that specific type of expertise but
we're a little unsure as to why we would
want to step to
to institute either another layer of
bureaucracy where
along the line of everything that's
being done there's also now a
legislative committee that's also going
to have to be dealt with in terms of the
the structure and the decisions that are
made on a real-time basis
at our home we don't think that that's
gonna those of you with a business
background can probably count on one
hand the number of times you've said you
know if i just put another layer of
bureaucracy in my business things will
run so much smoother so um the truth is
we think that that the way things are
are currently organized are are doing
well the
the group is the home is inspected
annually by the va
i'll tell you that you know va
government type inspections are a big
deal they look at everything that you do
from soup to nuts in your budget and
everything else
they coordinate with
the department of public health under
dhhs already
they coordinate with the center for
disease control every every one of the
practices that's in place at our
veterans home is in keeping with the
best practices of our nursing homes
across the state already uh the
commandant who is sitting behind me on
my right commandant labreck does in fact
coordinate with other other nursing
homes and and works to get best
practices in our in our veterans home
all the time infectious infection
control those kinds of things those kind
of procedures and having the va as as
someone who not only provides funding
but helps helps us in situations like we
got into last year where we had several
staff members that contracted cobin and
they needed some additional staffing and
the va was able to provide that that
staffing and those folks came in and it
was transparent to the residents of of
the home
the decisions and the rules that are
made up there have to go through the
joint legislative committee
on administrative rules here at the
state already
the legislative budget folks audit the
books at the veterans home periodically
like they do other agencies that are
that are already in the racket stack in
terms of
of oversight
um so
i want to kind of leave you with this
thought um it's it's always been my
you know my thought that if if it isn't
broke then don't fix it and you know i i
know this other study was done and not
not a lot of the recommendations were
carried through on and i'm not sure what
has changed between now and then i know
we've had a pandemic that was hard on
all of the nursing homes in the state
but i want you to take this statistic
with you when you leave here because i
found it really encouraging from january
the 1st of 2021
until january until december the 31st of
2021 the entire calendar year 2021 not a
single resident at the new hampshire
veterans home tested positive for cover
19.
not a single one so when you look at
that kind of level of competence and
excellence um i'm not sure that adding
you know more oversight or looking at
this i'm not sure what the problem is
that we're that we're necessarily trying
to solve here uh like i said commandant
lebrecus here if you have specific
questions on how their operation works
she certainly is the best person to
address those two but if there's any
other questions as to how the committee
thinks about this i'd be happy to answer
them at this time
thank you for your testimony are there
questions from the committee
i have one simple question
does
the board of managers still have a world
war one vet veteran specified world war
one i i would think not that person
would have to be a about
122 years old yeah that was the
that was the one of the recommendations
from the previous study
i know that presently there are two uh
at the at the re at the convenience of
the governor or at the pleasure of the
government governor slots one of them is
currently vacant
but and usually those are residents of
the actual home
thank you other questions
representative
thank you um could you please uh
did you happen to read the 2014 report
and can you comment on that please i
have not read the 2014 report ma'am i'm
sorry
arizona fellows um yes thank you can you
just tell me again
what is the group that you're
representing i'm representing the state
veterans advisory committee
we're chartered by state rsa uh there
are 20 member organizations in that
group and those should be
familiar toward to you they're things
like the veterans of foreign wars the
american legion
represents relatives from all the
services i personally represent the air
force association on that board but we
also have uh the navy league the marine
corps league
uh the the military order the purple
heart we have a couple of motorcycle
organizations that are on there like
rolling thunder and and groups like that
as well we have a korean war veterans
group that's on there
thank you other questions
represent scitec
mr grady i'm not particularly pushing
this bill i don't know how i feel about
it but i'm impressed by how high your
back is up on this um
if your thing is doing doing so well you
should be proud please to have the
committee come back and say pat on the
back what i'm thinking is
uh you're a quasi state agency and while
this isn't exactly the same we do have
lba audits of all state agencies whether
they're operating well or not people
come in and look them over with fresh
eyes
and i'm thinking this is
uh
in some sense roughly equivalent what
what are you concerned about i mean so
there's a committee looking at the
operation there may be some good ideas
coming out of it maybe not but we'll
listen one you know
it just seems that you're
i've stepped on your toe and it sounds
like you need surgery is what it sounds
like
uh sir i'm i'm sorry if i came across
that way uh and i will tell you that
that when i come and speak to the
committees here i'm i'm i'm trying to
convey to you the discussion that we had
in january in our in our group
and that these are the kinds of things
kind of points that were raised by our
members uh when they discussed this
issue and came uh to their conclusion uh
that and
in terms of
there's there's always an opportunity
for good ideas the the people who are on
the board of managers are published on
their website
it's easy enough to get a hold of those
folks and make suggestions and um again
there's there's not a lot we can do if
you're if you want to put together a
committee you're obviously the
legislature and you can do that if you
want to
mr grady i'm going to apologize they
came a little strong you did a good job
of representing your
your constituents
uh it's just
i still wonder why they're so concerned
but i appreciate your job and i'm sorry
yes sir
again
i'm just uh i i don't take offense with
your uh with your question but i did
need you to understand that our our
members do feel fairly strongly about
this about this issue in that
we feel that there is already adequate
supervision now if there's a way that we
get state supervision
in addition to what we have now
and
periodically because we are a state you
know quasi-state organization then then
so be it for that but
for those of us who have been involved
with the military and have had military
inspections and the va is just like any
other military inspection when you're in
a combat unit you know you you work
really hard and you hope that your
results show that you're that you're
doing the right things and that you're
you're showing the best practices and
that's that's what's been the case at
our uh at our inspections
thank you are there other questions
okay seeing none thank you for your
testimony
is there any other person who would wish
to testify on house bill 1314
i would like to make sure
yes
yes any other
public testimony
all right seeing none i will close the
public hearing
thank you for coming
madam chair i'd like to just commend the
veterans home for for navigating through
2021 with no cases of cove but that that
would almost seem impossible frankly in
the fact that that did occur is uh
i think a glowing testament to your
operations
you